all right guys I'm Greg I'm John so
after getting up the biggest ones from
comic-con we thought we got all them
done all the comic-con releases that
people were requesting you're looking
through all the comments there's still
one left that people have been
requesting yeah Westworld questworld
season two Jonny Quest John and I did
watch all of West world did in like two
days you extra follow us on the TV time
app because we actually use that thing
we do and this ain't a sponsored video
whatsoever it's a good app just you'll
light so you're good at your prompt
checking it out follow the real reason
when I keep track of all your shows and
stuff and when they're airing it's about
yeah yeah I'm telling you guys worth it
and last thing I want to mention Dunkirk
review will be up tomorrow
two more in a little while longer to
edit than any of these reaction boots
you got pretty excited too I shouldn't
have to as laird as I am bro most
compact they're really excited to be
huntresses probably this might be the
ones for me but ya know that appeals
they all the things coming out of San
Diego and I think books convention today
I'm pretty excited about Wes world that
pianos back robotic piano
now all the blood Casso standing sorry
of course stop I want to live
oh and you're here watching this tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are using em now not oh man oh dear what
is having these human that's her she's
killing oh wow
[Music]
heroes of the different look good 32 and
then in black still survived well
ah oh I miss this yeah I do too that was
cool you do so many shows you missed
them after a while yeah long time since
we've since we watched it was a while
ago and I'm excited to see it because I
mean if anyone knew the west-world story
whether you read the book or you already
there's a Booker hmm
yeah isn't that baby Michael Christian's
right no Krishan Michael Chris Michael
krutov Michael well I read the book or
seen the UM your movie
yeah I've seen that movie I was aware
that you think this is supposed to be
like you know Jurassic Park but with
robots like ever it's a theme park and
then halfway through oh my god the
robots are rebelling AI so we're all
waiting for that and season one was this
major build-up to that with a lot of
exploration as beyond just build-up and
yeah it's like it's like the precipice
of artificial intelligence and like the
little things that bring the the big
push into place yeah it's more than just
robot growing evil yeah there's a much
bigger plan in mind and that that was
exciting and intense now we're getting
to see that part of this chapter of West
world when the artificial intelligence
is raining what it's just its own rules
of humans trapped there what are they
gonna do to them you know what's what's
I'm really wondering what's the show
going to be you know they had some great
storylines that was a lot of mystery a
lot of questions that were being asked
and I'm wondering is this one going to
be a little more direct because you see
that there's so some human characters so
alive after get all their names right
now to be honest but you know that when
the Hemsworth brothers still alive the
douchey guys writers are yeah he's still
alive and he looks like he's being now
manipulated by Mei Mei for lying under
Nick vision yeah I want to make Funko
pop yeah I love that because being
manipulated sue is because you know
she's like the master manipulator of the
a spy the smartest one is the most
clever girl yeah in Evan Rachel Wood
seems like she is going full-on hog and
I'm wondering - with Ed Harris's
character what's his plan now cuz he had
this whole question
he had a whole specific storyline about
finding one specific thing and now he's
found the answer to that what does he
want to do - wanted Coulier I don't like
what's his deal so it's making me wonder
if or danger is there going to be a
mystery question the Anthony Hopkins
character leave behind something else
for these people to explore - have
questions - to try to find something to
uncover is it going to be one of those
things where even though he's dead gonna
be like a jigsaw the tape at the end
yeah every single episode is going to
end with some kind of twist the Anthony
Hopkins plan this all is important it's
just going to be a pretty direct
straightforward season to where AI is
now rebelling and there's some human
characters left so it's humans versus
the AI in the world of West world yeah
like are you going to be just trapped in
a real Wild West but where the the robot
yeah it just happens to be you know
robot because one of the greatest things
about the first season was the mystery
and hand from wanting to know all the
answers to everything and then we got
plenty of answers they're gonna just set
up a whole bunch of brand-new questions
honestly it's been so long can't even
really remember off the top of my head
there's questions that were left open I
mean I mostly remember it was that big
shocking one Wow telling everyone after
Anthony Hopkins gets shot that's the
beginning of something that that's
what's cool to me about this I don't
really know what to expect
other than wildness I don't even need a
trailer I just tell them I'll watch the
show you just tell me season two's that
yeah this is I don't use repick love
that's so pretty epic to me and that's
something yeah the first season part of
what I liked about that so much is the
sort of subtle build-up of things and
the fact that you know even little tiny
emotional experiences are kind of a big
deal for the robots in Coleco decks
totally now they seem to kind of more be
taking hold you know are the rest are
all of them going to wake up this way it
seems like the the first season ends on
the beginning of something new part of
me has no idea what to expect and part
of me wonders if it's just going to be
linear you know we're going right into
the Wild West of westward yeah where
there is no more control you know or the
control has drastically shifted you know
have you ever seen everything film
theories video on where
Westworld is located no oh dude it's a
fascinating video guy you got to check
that video activates at this point in
the video stop watching this video don't
even hit subscribers your name just go
to the build Theory Channel and look for
the west-world video where they break
down where they believe Wes world is
located honestly there's some time to
hear some things from film theory and
you're like that's just a theory but
then there are some things like that
video room like I think they are
probably right about it I don't really
know what's coming but it sure looks
gripping yeah alright guys well are you
excited for Westworld season 2 and if
you've seen Wes world who's your
favorite character from this show
mine was Evan Rachel Wood mine was that
one scientist guy with the beard the guy
who's always like freaking out about
having it yeah my favorite actor
definitely 100% it's hard cheese mints
or to pick your favorite kids he was hot
and hard my dad picked me of this thing
my children yeah I forgot great already
struggle to read any families family
she's a millinery my siblings good but
I'm not great that's one yeah he said
look subscribe to the real rejects we
got notification about that John Haase
remember to read
Instagram he works for Blum house.com go
check it out
he's a social media manager Blum house
this was one of our quick
patreon.com/scishow to reject all the
Comic Con videos we got to keep the
review part short ya know and then this
one I was like I think I'm rambling
screw it and who cares everyone's
watching the store justice leaders do
whatever we wanted this moment and maybe
would nobody would know I'm just yet
didn't long look at it